Nazi it feels like a highlight of this
tournament for you has been your opening
preparation you're just getting better
position uh positions out of the opening
in pretty much every single game did you
do anything specific like how many hours
were you preparing before this event yes
every single day last year at the U.S
Champs I did really badly so I took my
time to come prepare this time
I don't have a coach or anything but I
did spend really a lot of time and today
I got a special Lucky in the first game
because I had this position on the board
in my room in your preparation yes all
the way up until you got the decisive
Advantage yes I expected in like earlier
C5 instead of 97 and A6
but I think she just exactly is
um I think she just blundered upon her
to maybe on D take C5 at least she
should take with the Knight yes but I
should still be better you can take on
D5 get the isolated Queen spawn and that
should give you an advantage
yeah so this game went about as well as
you could have gone did you feel like
you're letting it slip away or did you
feel in full control the whole time I
felt in full control and I made sure to
not give her any uh counter-attacking
chances because she's so good at that I
made sure my king was safe
um yeah it fun it uh felt pretty smooth
and how about the second game there was
some pressure coming from her side in
the second one yeah I was not happy with
Queen C7 as soon as I made that move
my idea was that if she plays C5 I'm
gonna go Bishop H to check King H1
Bishop takes E2 and then Bishop F4 but
then I immediately realized that she can
take with the queen on E2
um
okay maybe it's still fine but and that
doesn't allow you to go beach before
because take take it and then two ropes
I can take on D4 but
honestly didn't want to play this in uh
in Rapid yeah yeah absolutely especially
with the King stuck on the eighth rank
looks dangerous right yeah any sort of
imbalances you don't want to see that
exactly so I ended up in this very
passive position and I think after
Knight F4 Bishop G6 if she went
immediate D5 here I was pretty worried
yes yes that was in fact the best one
according to the engine as well you had
some ideas to tame the position but it
wasn't easy at this point yeah so I was
happy when she delayed D5 and 1p4 that
gave me time to improve my position I
think I'm still slightly worse but at
least I felt like I could hold this yes
and it did feel like finally you managed
to be accurate and not let her get a
dangerous passport
this one on C5 most likely and you did
find a way to do just that were you
worried at all about this long diagonal
I was I was repeating to myself if she
goes Queen E3 don't allow Queen E5
yes you don't want to see the queen land
on E5 that's for sure which it didn't uh
and this was the position and after that
at this point I would assume once you
took on C6 you understood this is it the
match is mine here I could relax finally
yes absolutely tomorrow you will be
facing uh begin to kill Genova or do you
have I will ask you the same thing as I
asked her to you have any experience
against her how would you assess that
imagine what are you going to do special
for it I think I think I played her
twice in the last two years
championships Only In classical games
uh
I don't know her that well but I'm gonna
continue preparing as well as I have and
we'll see what happens guys any
questions yeah absolutely first of all
our congratulations to you Naji uh you
mentioned that you don't have a chess
coach you don't have a chess coach so
how do you train yourself like a lot of
young ladies out there would like to ask
you the question how do you train
yourself you don't have a coach somebody
telling you what you're supposed to do I
don't like people telling me
that's why I don't have a code yeah
I haven't had a coach since I was 16
years old
mainly because like I said I'm pretty
stubborn I like to play what I like to
play and I don't like to compromise and
the way to study on your own is just
if you love The Game and you're
disciplined we all have computers chest
based engine it's pretty easy
there you go stubborn I like it you see
you you you you yeah you you keep to
what you know oh congratulations good
luck in your next match thank you
you like our answer there that's how you
do it you just you got your engines yeah
I mean it's very much just a person